[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Nick
Murray published this essay in a uh
financial
planning uh Pro periodical that I got a
hold of this week one of my buddies sent
it to me in the business very well done
and he's kind of he's kind of a snarky
like you George that's why I like him I
like just reading this article yeah the
persistent illusion of
gold this is good yeah for the second
for the record the subtitle of the Wall
Street Journal piece is swing in stocks
and bonds have boosted the Metal's
popularity with ordinary Investments the
statistic at the heart of the article is
the percentage of Americans who believe
gold is the best long-term investment
jumped to 26% this year from 15% in 2022
according to a Gallop report from May in
contrast those preferring stocks dropped
to 18% from 24% last year while those
favoring bonds climbed to 7% from 4%
this happens quite reliably every time
there's a bare Market in stocks ordinary
investors are always recalibrating their
preferences in the rear view
mirror my which is wrong my major
purpose in this little essay is to parse
through the pathology which persists in
the illusion not just that gold is an
efficient inflation hedge but that it's
somehow preferable to holding a broadly
Diversified portfolio of high quality
Common Stocks like a mutual fund for the
long term first let's get our
terminology straight gold is not not in
any accepted sense and investment at all
that is it does not produce anything it
just sits there goal's sole Financial
function is as an inflation hedge the
question then becomes how's that working
out in August of 71 the price of gold
was arbitrarily fixed at $35,000 an
ounce $35 an ounce by January of 80 the
last time ordinary investors went
totally Gaga over it gold had reached
$800 an ounce thus if you bought an
ounce of gold nearly 4 4 years ago at
$800 you now own an ounce of gold that
is at this writing worth
$1,965 that's up about two and a half
times having produced in the interim
neither dividends nor interest nor
anything else it now becomes my painful
duty to disclose to you that the
Consumer Price Index in January of 80
stood at 78 in July of this year it was
306 just shy of four times which means
that to have kept up with inflation your
$800 gold ounce would have to be valued
at 3200 but it isn't it's at 1,900 not
even close so not much of an inflation
hedge uh wait it gets worse the standard
and po 500 stock index the end of
January 80 was
115 uh as of right now it's in the
4490 and uh that's right while the price
of gold was Rising 2 and a half times
the S&P 500 went up 39 times not
counting dividends which at the risk of
repeating oneself gold does not pay with
reinvested dividends and assuming you
paid taxes from another source $800
invested in the S&P in January uh of
1980 left a compound would currently be
worth
$95,000 not
$1,900 there's the difference in mutual
funds and gold mic drop you can't even
argue with that I mean the guy just laid
it out so beautifully boom in your face
boom so I read somewhere that gold is
actually a pretty effective inflation
hedge over extremely long periods
perhaps a century or more not true
either by the way if you go back and
pull gold since the 1800s it has an
average annual of about
2.2% where the S&P has an average annual
of about 11.8% how is that an inflation
hedge it's not it's
mythology it it's gold has the
mysterious ability to make people look
like
idiots it really it's mysterious I mean
they make they they say things that are
just
blatantly not factual and believe things
that are blatantly not factual because
it is a Shiny Rock I do not understand
but I'll tell you what from 1980 to
today you could put $800 in and you'd
have
$95,000 or you could put $800 in gold
and you'd have
$1900
ouch I don't know how anyone could just
be doing the math on that going well
Dave I just I sleep better night no when
I got gold in case the economy crashes I
got 1,900 instead of
95,000 I'll help you with your sleep
we've played this game cuz we've played
it out of what happens let's see that
every company goes to zero that's what
would have to happen for the stock
market to go to zero every company goes
bankrupt tell if the stock market had
grown from 800 to 1900 since
1980 the American economy would have
collapsed yeah would have collapsed
because that would have meant that that
the typical company is losing money that
the average is that horrible I mean for
the stock market to be that anemic the
economy would have to be that anemic and
it would just be I mean I don't know if
our society would have survived if the
stock market had done the same rates of
return that gold had done wow think
about that yeah that's wild I mean you
would had to make nothing on your I mean
Gees
like yeah so these people are scared of
the stock market hey if this collapses
I'll have my gold bars and it'll somehow
keep its value in these dark times but
they've lost so much money that and it
hasn't even kept up with inflation that
I'm going I'll be way better off than
you just Haven been the tortoise over
here investing in the stock market for
30 40 years yeah well it's about as dumb
as the guy called me up and said you
know I got $400,000 I buried it in
coffee cans in my backyard that's an
inflation hedge Dave um no it's paper
money and Buri it in the ground this is
not going to go well buddy
uh we're talking insects we're talking
dampness we're talking well I sealed the
C I don't care well even if the buried
it in the ground do you not know those
things rust um and now what happens when
you die your Rel your hillbilly
relatives are out there with their metal
detectors I would make that a reality
show I'd watch that on HDTV that's about
as dumb wow you know well and your
$40,000 40 years later having sit in the
ground ain't worth $40,000 oh was 400
,000 oh my gosh so I told him you're
losing $40,000 a year it been 10 years I
said you've lost you you know you've
lost $400,000 what do you mean I didn't
I don't I didn't lose it I know where it
is no you lost what you could have made
another $400,000 in 10 years on this
millions and meanwhile it's sitting back
there doing absolutely nothing your 800
could have become 95 but you put it in
gold and it became 95,000 and you put it
in Gold it became
1900 Nick you did a good job with this
article I don't know you personally I
hope we get to meet someday but your
analysis uh and your critical thinking
skills are dead on um yeah the it is not
proper to say that gold or any other
commodity is an investment it is a
speculation but it's not an investment
it reminds me of cry Investments
Investments have a an income that they
produce they have something going along
with them even real estate when you buy
it and it doesn't have an income
associated with it you're looking for is
the increase in value now you're
speculating rather than
investing you know that speculators lose
money investors make money well over the
years as you've been doing this Dave
most people are drawn to this out of
fear which is usually not a great reason
to do anything financially fear or greed
yeah you're right yeah it it it it it's
not I mean right after I get afraid I
get stupid because I'm in freakout mode
and my critical thinking skills shut
down I'm in the middle of a trauma
experience well usually I saw a headline
of some guy yelling at them go buy gold
it's all coming down guys go buy gold
and silver you'll be okay and uh it
doesn't work out like that and it fall
goes down we're not going to be looking
for gold I'm not going to be looking to
trade Dave Ramsey for gold I need food
bullets shelter water ammo yep bullets
bullets and ammo both both of those well
Dave you're loading up over here George
I'm going to Dave's compound if it all
goes down so I'm okay you guys fend for
yourselves yeah so Nick Murray uh that
did this essay is quoting from the
August 7th uh online edition of The Wall
Street Journal the article that he was
uh picking apart was titled when markets
get scary mom and pop by gold uh so not
Mom and Pop That want to be wealthy if
you want to build
wealth typically what we find is people
buy real estate and they buy mutual
funds and they pay cash for their real
estate no debt these are the typical
paths that we find among millionaires we
don't find millionaires to say I got
rich buying
gold and now we know why cuz 800 in 1980
turned into
today and what is that 50 years 40 years
later 45 years later wow in 45 years you
doubled your money
barely well don't dance in the street
over that